we fought really hard to get to that
point where we can break bread together
and live together and respect one
another
and it is now coming from the left to
break us back down and send us back to
the sick to you know
everything my i your point that it now
is coming from the left is one that i've
been pondering
i had think that it's
always been the left that the
the left the democratic party everybody
says
that lyndon johnson somehow had this
conversion and he stopped being racist
and he signed the civil rights act of
1964
and the democratic party all just
changed and they love black people
i don't believe that i believe that
tactics change that the agenda stays the
same
but people adapt different tactics and
that's why last week and i got a lot of
heat for this for saying
hey black lives matter antifa they
operate the way the kkk operated the kkk
was started in the 1860s after the
emancipation proclamation
it was the enforcement arm of the
democratic party
the agenda was to impose
force people to support democratic
politician uh politics
and uh to keep black people
in a substandard condition here in
america
i don't think things changed in the
1960s i think the tactics changed
you could no longer lynch people
technology basically eliminated that
because now people have phones in their
homes you can call the police the kkk
comes to your house and tries to pull
you out of there you can call the police
and they
you can't lynch people anymore it's too
easy to get caught
we started prosecuting people so we no
longer lynch people but we do
bully them through social media
campaigns you have black lives matter
antifa they will come to your home and
intimidate you they'll take instead of
and take your way of living to instead
of burning crosses we have burning
buildings
and then if you look at the policies
that the democratic party
adopted from the 60s on the elimination
and the destruction of the black
family intentional intentional in my
and and so basically we've infused black
people if you just go look at it we've
infused
black people with a racist mindset an
anti-black mindset instead of the kkk or
a white racist person being most likely
to use the n-word
it's now us instead of the kkk
killing us it's now us killing each
other
in record numbers in our own communities
it's it's now instead of us putting out
blackface music or
entertainment instead of white people
doing that
we now have rappers that do that and put
out these
very negative stereotypes about black
people and we celebrate this as our
culture
we have been turned into our own worst
enemy
we act and have adopted the mindset of
the kkk
and we're doing it at the behest of the
democratic party and i'm sorry if that
pisses me
off i think it's true you know that the
black lives matter website
said one of their goals was to disrupt
your family they're doing its other
races
i don't know if we're are we is it
technically are we different races i
don't know if that's the right word to
use but whatever
but like i hate white people they say
uh the white knight concept of a guy
that's like i side with the feminists so
i do
i dislike men like they're turning men
against men in that sense or
um i should be guilty because of my skin
color like they're trying to turn me
against
that that race or whatever yeah no no no
no
democratic party it's just about
make people racially conscious so that
they have negative stereotypes to people
based on race
i don't think you know there's a lot of
like alt-right people who think that
they want white people to dislike
themselves or something no i think it's
just divide and conquer they don't care
who hates who as long as people don't
like each other
that way the heat is taken off the
establishment they don't want i think it
started with occupy wall street
because i remember my first real
encounter with the critical race theory
crazies was at occupy
and it was like after i saw
conservatives and libertarians down
there and i was like wow that's crazy
but then it went so it went straight up
progressively it really started with
um 911 where they turned us against the
middle eastern people no that unifying
color well the unified amer
white skin people against dark skinned
it wasn't about race though it
it kind of was it was about religion
they were like muslims are dangerous put
a
but then it was like who's who's muslim
primarily in the world is people in the
middle east the target of 9 11
after so after this was saddam hussein
and the taliban yeah but they made us
afraid of a of a certain people first
like xenophobia
it was a target of a country and the
idea of terrorism
they unified this country against its
perceived enemy terror
and so there was no heat on the
establishment george w bush's approval
rating skyrocketed
this country came together in anger in a
direction the establishment could
weaponize
but we didn't let me ask you this before
you go
are you sure it's any different and i'm
asking i don't know
the japanese were responsible or we say
were for pearl harbor
what 9 11 they flew planes into the
building
i can't be mad at the middle east people
or
saddam hussein or uh osama bin laden
for flying osama bin laden for flying
those planes into
america i can't be mad at the japanese
for for pearl harbor
i mean well those were actually
organized
and the anger was pointed at the problem
is when the japanese american civilians
got thrown in tournament camps because
the japanese empire
yeah so like if osama bin laden or
whoever it was
destroyed some buildings as a small
group of terror to go after civilians
in our own country in response i thought
i think was heavy-handed
sure but for the most part if the
establishment can unify this country
but as a weapon against thing you know
the enemies to empower the establishment
like
they wanted to go to war in the middle
east for a variety of reasons
there's strategic positioning around
iran then you've got qatar turkey
pipeline there's always an excuse for
what's going to rally americans but
something started changing
with mass media when we had syria and
the gas attack
you had a lot of people on the left
saying they didn't believe it they
didn't believe the propaganda against
assad
and then you had people on the right
saying there's got to be a red line it
wasn't necessarily the right of the left
we're at a point now where they can't
unify us
because we're mad at them and every
attempt they make to point the finger at
someone else
it just comes right back to the
establishment elites because we figured
it out
the mask has come off the curtain is
falling and we're like hey wait a minute
hey wait a minute you've been
manipulating us this whole time
you listen 911 was was a nightmarish
scenario for this country
nightmare never forget and so was pearl
harbor
and what did they do they took us at our
weakest when we were scared when we were
angry and we wanted justice
and many of us were emotional i was just
a kid and they said it was that guy who
did it go kill him
and we said yes sir for america we will
have justice
and then we realized it was fake it was
a lie they tricked us
they sent us overseas this nation to
iraq and afghanistan for what there were
no weapons of mass destruction they
weren't involved it was a
lie they manipulated us at our weakest
moment that's what they do and now
people are
finally realizing we are done with this
and so are we when they elected a
reality tv guy well right but also but
i want to ask this because and this is
where
i disagree with a lot of people i think
the siege of the capitol is the most
overplayed thing
this alleged insurrection where i never
saw one of these trump supporters
that i've seen draw a gun and and so
i've watched nancy pelosi and mitch
mcconnell
basically stand up and they're pulling
it off oh my god did you see
the trump people they tried to overthrow
the government
all because we're protecting you and
people are going for it yeah
because i'm looking at i'm like hey man
i watched all of 2020 people burn down
buildings
loot riot kill police officers and
they're acting like this thing at the
capitol
was worse than what i saw in minneapolis
kenosha atlanta
l.a and the stuff that's going on in new
york and chicago 9 11.
and i'm like hey man i've watched the
video i keep
looking for this crazy insurrection and
i just don't see it
you remember remember the officer i
think it was in vegas he was just out
because there were riots or
uh and and so he was just standing
around and so one of these rioters is
walking away and just turns and fires
two shots and keeps walking
hits him in the head paralyzes the guy
why
yeah they don't care about this they
don't care about this right it's because
the centralized authority another
problem about having like
congress people people are going for
this capital thing it's because the
people
at the capitol that got most affected by
it are the politicians yeah
and it's because that all that power is
centralized in these 450 people
that it's so vulnerable that if those
guys get messed with the whole system
shutters
they don't what happened to him i think
tim just said he's from the south side
of chicago
i've been in some neighborhoods in
indianapolis where helicopters
gunshots kids are traumatized on a
nightly basis
nancy pelosi had some people in a wolves
uniform
coming to the capitol and she's acting
like she's a kid on the south side
that she's been traumatized i tell you
man i i used to
spend a lot of my time covering conflict
around the world you know i worked for
vice i went to egypt
i was in ukraine it's in venezuela and i
always had people ask me like did you
train for this like it's got to be scary
people are shooting i was in ferguson
people were shooting live ammo
and i was like oh no no i'm just from
the south side of chicago
i was like dude i went to uk i went to
ukraine during the start of the
euromaidan movement which eventually led
to the ousting of yanukovych
and you know there was mods of cocktails
there were guns i got surrounded by
people i was in turkey
i went to one neighborhood where a bunch
of guys surrounded me pushed me up
against the wall and held a molotov
cocktail to my face
and i'm cool as a cucumber man i'm like
people are like aren't you scared
we were filming when that happened too
i'm not trying to brag i'm just like
dude in chicago
you want to talk about growing up with
like dude high school fights where i'm
from people had guns and so people would
scream and run
and we were laughing as we were running
from the guns it's like it's just you
grow up in this man
dude if you're black and my we're
we've been conditioned we go to night
clubs where we have to go through metal
detectors to get inside the nightclub
commonplace almost every black knight
metal detector is to make sure you
weren't carrying a gun and so we've been
conditioned to normalize this
but but i'm just looking at this capital
thing and i'm going
there are kids in communities that are
hearing gunshots every night
their cousins have been killed they're
my
uncles somebody's been shot he's ganged
up these kids are traumatized on a daily
basis and no one cares
but the cat but nancy pelosi oh my god
she hid under
a desk or something it's like it's it's
look it's bad it is
but you know ian's right it was it's the
nucleus when that got hit it shook the
whole system
but i'll tell you why the establishment
elites the people with power
the politicians they don't care about
you so they don't know
when the they're not there they're not
getting they're not getting their
windows shut up but i'll tell you why
it's true it's true but there's some
truth there just like true
when i got here today you told me that
there were no police
basically yeah and that was something i
didn't know
welcome to the wilderness man yeah that
was so the so to clarify there are cops
but i try explaining this to my my very
lefty friends who grew up in cities i'm
like you realize people who live in the
middle of nowhere
don't have a local police department to
rush to you like you've got to take care
of yourself
for me that's no big deal i grew up on
the south side of chicago where you
pretty much can't trust the cops anyway
to do anything for you and
to to be fair a lot of them are bad cops
but also a lot of them are overwhelmed
with how crazy things can get
so i get it and i've always just been
like i gotta rely on myself
but to the point about pelosi i think
look
they know what's going on in chicago
they've not experienced it
i don't think they care i think they
hear about it in the news and they're
like yeah well what else is new
and then to them never experiencing it
finally having
you know i tell you when i saw some of
these videos of like the bumbling and
bewildered
you know older folks walking through the
capitol and then i see these people
panicking and like ducking and hiding
i'm like really like you've got these
pictures of the politicians and they're
like laying down
hiding and i'm like these people for the
most part weren't armed now i do think
there was some real danger because some
of these people seem to have been really
nuts
really really crazy many of them i
believe most were probably just
befuddled
like the cops opened the door in several
instances and people just walked in with
little flags and didn't know what was
going on
i was surprised to see you know there's
this meme that's really funny
it shows the p these politicians laying
down and hiding with gas masks on and
says
these are the people who send your kids
to go fight in wars and die
yep and look the other way as bodies
pile up in cities all over america
but if a white cop kills somebody black
the whole country shuts down
everybody takes a knee at arenas and
stadiums all across the country
and george floyd becomes
the mlk of this generation and
and i just want to add here i had a
cousin that i helped raise
that i helped that i loved i paid for
his funeral killed by the police killed
by sheriffs in indianapolis
i am not uncaring
about police brutality but
i'm also not a liar that is not
again my father never left the hood
built a brand new house in the hood he
carried a 38
he had a alarm system at his home and it
wasn't to protect himself from the
police
let's quit telling that lie and the
masterpiece lounge in the inner city of
indianapolis my favorite place on earth
my dad's bar we weren't sitting around
oh my god
hope i can make it home hope the police
don't kill me on the way home
when somebody and when a man walked you
to your car
woman in my dad's bar it wasn't to
protect you from the police
it was from the dudes that walk them
streets in that neighborhood
i'll never forget the la my dad died and
i threw a big party at his bar at the
masterpiece lines just we're cl
my brother wanted to keep the bar and i
was like jim we ain't built for this
we're not like my father
we we can't and we're closing it up at
3am
and right outside the door the back door
two dudes are beating the living hell
out of another dude
bottles upside the head and uh and i can
remember i told my brother i said
you think we built to run this business
when this is going on every night
this ain't us we too solved for this you
know i grew up i grew up with some
really bad stories about cops i've had
cops kick the door into my apartment
with at gunpoint i've been while
covering a protest in chicago surrounded
by cops at gunpoint a lot of just really
nasty stuff yeah i was there
yeah that's right luke was filming it
they put the gun to my head after i
check out the video
that's a common occurrence so we dealt
with this that was in chicago
and i'll tell you this though i've had
some bad experiences but i've also been
saved from a mugging by a group of cops
and a lot of people i guess you don't if
you don't experience these things you
don't really get it
but i was in uh i was on the north side
of chicago and
i don't know how that was i was like 20
years old i was i'm broke hanging out
with my friends
crossing the street and some dude he
comes up to me and he starts basically
threatening me
telling me i gotta give him he asked me
for my money can i have your money man
come on
let me get your money i'm just trying to
do the right thing and i laugh i'm like
i don't got any money dude
i was like i'm a 20 year old dude i'm
broke and so he kept pressuring me
he had a guy following about 15 feet
behind basically a spotter
something goes wrong his buddy comes up
and helps him i pull out my empty wallet
literally nothing but an id in it
and then he's like i know you got money
in your shoe i know you got money you
think i'm stupid i got a knife
and then i started laughing i'm just
laughing i'm like what is this guy gonna
do is he gonna like frisk me i don't got
money
all of a sudden it's like it's like a
split second i have no idea what
happened
i just get like kind of pushed to the
side and this big dude in this overcoat
grabs the guy by the front of his collar
spins him around and slams him into a
fence
and screams in his face spit flying not
in my
town and then out of nowhere two uniform
beat cops
are behind me and i'm like what is going
on they pull me aside like you okay sir
and i'm like yeah
yeah they cuffed the guy they took his
information they were like we've been
watching these dudes
we're we're you know we're tracking them
trying to see we didn't know what they
were up to we're glad we were here and i
was like
cool it's like wow and i i have more bad
experience than positive ones
to be completely honest but that was an
amazing experience
where they shook my hand told me you
know everything cool you're all right
have a good day sir we caught him in the
act we don't even need you as a witness
and i was like all right that was it
turns out the guy actually lived in the
south side not too far from me by the
way so it's
a funny story but i think people
you know get too much of the negative
propaganda when it comes to cops because
it's shocking
and it it it plays well it gets shares
world view by anecdotes
yeah rather than data facts and we have
an
anecdote driven society and that's very
dangerous
and i don't understand why congress our
lawmakers haven't focused in
the biggest spreader of misinformation
disinformation
information that makes people vibe it's
it's twitter it's not
parlor yeah and they never go after
twitter
it's i don't jack dorsey to me
is one of the five most powerful people
in america
who is he did we vet this guy is he's
not an elected official
but he gets to decide public discourse
the tone of it
who gets to speak whose voice gets
amplified the
guy has an incredible amount of power
and i don't know who he is and neither i
don't think most of america knows who he
is
it seems ridiculous that we're shutting
down parlor
and no one's looking at twitter
facebook two my buddy posted a video
that has uh it's a clip of anthony fauci
saying
masks you don't need masks are not
needed they
they don't do what you think they do
they give people a false sentence from
security from like i think
end of march or april and then facebook
masked it and said this has partially
false information
and ben was like what the [ __ ] you was
wrong
it was out of context it was just a clip
but it was he was very clear
saying you don't need them they they
don't give you the the benefits well i
think they do gold
it's an old video so his position has
changed he was emphatic
and he's been in the industry for 70
some or he's 80 70.
so he's been doing this for decades and
for him to not know
after 30 years of serving in this in his
position to not know that masks are
effective or not well now he wants you
to wear two of them yeah three
cnbc wants you to wear three of them so
he spent 20 or 30 years studying this
stuff and then within eight months he
completely did it a 180 degree
turn wasn't there a meme where like you
said someone's smothering their gram
with a pillow yes
that's the only way to put that is these
enough matte are these enough masks
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you